why do they keep giving new people the
superhero Mantle's or changing them when
they make the movies why can't they just
make new characters if they want
diversity all right let's talk about
that hey everybody
time for a nice little lgbtq+ sort of
area ramble we'll see how this goes I
have notes but I didn't script this one
so yeah the question that I've seen pop
up more than a few times when things get
announced that appear to be changing a
formally usually straight white sis male
character into something that diverges
from any of those four tends to get a
not great response we've seen that
plenty and I don't want to deal with all
of the arguments that tend to come up
there is one specific one that this
video is going to address and that is
this argument of why don't they this is
being done for inclusion and
representation why are you changing the
existing characters why don't you just
make new ones and the reason I want to
address that is because in a vacuum
that's valid I mean honestly if you want
to expand the diversity of a cast it
makes sense just to create new
characters rather than rewrite the ones
you've already got I mean there's no
reason not to in a vacuum on paper but
I'm gonna be talking about superheroes
and adaptations from superheroes and
pretty much focusing on the big two
Marvel and DC because I'm not gonna say
this is the only places these arguments
come up but they're certainly where they
come up the most frequently these days
because
superheroes are really big movie and TV
business right now so this is the the
framing through which I want to tackle
it and first of all let's acknowledge
exactly how prevalent is this well it's
been going on for a little while and
some examples from films that we already
have would include Tessa Thompson and
Idris Elba as Valkyrie and Heimdall in
the Thor films we've got Laurence
Fishburne playing Perry White in the DC
films Michael B Jordan was Johnny storm
and that one terrible Fantastic Four
movie we had zendaya as MJ and Jacob
battle on sorry if I mispronounced that
as Ned Leeds in both spider-man films
and presumably in the next one when that
happens and as far as upcoming Eternals
is like gonna be a massive indicator or
not indicated but continuation of this
sort of trend because you've got some
Hayek playing a Jack
Lauren Riddler playing Macari and and in
addition to the very obvious changes
she's also deaf which is gone which the
original character was not and she was
going to be portraying the character as
deaf you've got Donnelly is gilgamesh
Lea McHugh is sprite and also a very
recently at that time of recording zoe
kravitz got confirmed as Catwoman so ya
know this totally happens so the thing I
will immediately acknowledge this isn't
a one-off or an outlier when these
things happen the one the ones I
mentioned is not even comprehensive by
any means this sort of thing is going on
a fair amount when these characters are
getting adapted that changes are
happening that the casting is more
diverse than the cat then the characters
are on the page now of course when
people say the hole why don't you just
make an original character they don't
mean like for the movie they mean why
don't you create an original superhero
and then make a movie about that
superhero or at least I think that's
what they mean because if they're saying
create a complete
the original superhero character not
based on the comic like that's not the
try Guam what was the last completely
original superhero you ever heard of
like created for film I don't know
meteor man like that's not a thing I
think it happens like at all so here's
what I'm gonna do to sort of explain cuz
I know where I'm going with this but I'm
going to explain a couple things if
we're gonna compare a couple of decades
actually more than couple we're gonna
compare four decades worth of mainstream
superhero comic book writing and what
kind of new characters got introduced in
what volumes and so we're gonna be
talking 80's 90's 2000s 2010s and there
is a point to this this is context and I
and I'll come back around to it at the
end so stick with me so now keep in mind
this was not I'm not doing a super deep
dive on these and I'm gonna throw us the
numbers but they're by no means
comprehensive and I'm sure I certainly
missed people but this was the base
level research I've I did and it shows
the trend and so if I missed one or two
I don't think that severely breaks the
date in terms of the points that I'm
trying to make here so in the eighties
you had over 30 new notable superhero
characters introduced now this is gonna
come up in all the other ones do it this
includes ones who have stuck around and
we still know today as well as ones that
I'm sorry who is that so over at Marvel
you had characters like Kitty Pryde
Dazzler she-hulk Elektra rogue all
introduced in the 80s as well as
characters like Firestar Arachne and
Excalibur some of these are gonna be
teams DC introduced characters like
Raven cyborg Starfire
Jason Todd
and Tim Drake one through to Robbins
Lobo Booster Gold
and then also maxima vixen and Omega
matte in the 80s both Marvel and DC were
cranking out new characters at a similar
rate they were pretty close to each
other things started to diverge a little
bit after that though in the 90s Marvel
introduced way more new characters than
DC did DC spent the nineties really
going all in on events with their
existing characters because the 90s was
things like Death of Superman nightfall
whatever that Green Lantern thing was it
was the Emerald dawn I can't even I
can't remember whatever was called when
Hal Jordan went nuts so they were doing
lots of big events based around their
existing characters and not introducing
a ton of new ones at that point Marvel
was still introducing new ones though
not as many as they were in the 80s at
least not as many that you would
consider notable especially if you're
lumping teams that if you're counting
teams as one as opposed to all the
individuals because let's be honest you
know x-force you've heard of each
individual member of x-force so much
strong guy boom boom cannonball but
anyway some examples Marvel gave us
characters like cable gambit Deadpool
Bishop war machine and you know also
dark Hawk X Man Generation X and over at
DC Jesse quick static and Jack night
version of star man so you know not too
much going on over there the 2000s saw
things tick up again with both though
Marvel was still doing significantly
more than DC was so Marvel was
introducing characters like x-23 Bob
agents of Hydra Miles Morales and then
you know a bunch of people like black
fox buzz typeface spike freakshow I
don't know who these people are but
name's I found and over at DC the ones
that are important and have stuck around
would be Miss Martian the Jaime Reyes
version of Blue Beetle and then there's
the also-rans like king chimera 4runner
Knight Eagle Orpheus and in the 2010s
almost no new characters were introduced
at either one Marvel still did a couple
more than DC but neither of them did
very many Marvel gave us Kamala Khan
spider-gwen gwenpool
DC give us batwing and if you've been
paying attention you may noticed in the
2000s and the 2010s if you paid
attention to the names of characters
that have stuck around you may have
noticed something they're all derivative
of existing characters basically there
hasn't really been a truly new character
introduced superhero character
introduced at either Marvel or DC in the
last 20 years that has made significant
impact the closest I'd say you could
come would be maybe Kamala Khan because
she bares the least resemblance to the
character that she whose mantle she
takes that being Ms marvel but she is
still taking another character's mantle
she's got a completely different power
set completely different origins
completely different operating procedure
and the mo and everything else but they
still had to slap the name on it to get
it to take off new characters don't get
traction in superhero comics not anymore
this is part of why DC keeps rebooting
every five years and that's why DC has
virtually nothing in the 2010s because
2011 gave us the new 52 they weren't
going to introduce new characters they
were resetting all the ones they already
had I mean and even the one that I that
I caught back wing it's just one more
bat family member there were a ton of
them and then they did rebirth and like
reset the reset the things that sell
comics are the characters that have
already been around new characters will
get introduced in supporting roles as
[Music]
you know back up side characters friends
romantic interest maybe the actual
heroes the people who were here to see
new characters just don't make it I mean
they don't the new characters that have
made a notable impact since 2000 nearly
20 years
x-23 literally a gender flipped caught a
clone of Wolverine Miles Morales Spy ran
with a different origin and different
racial background Miss Martian
female but derivative of Martian
Manhunter Jaime Reyes he's the third
person to be the Blue Beetle Kamala Khan
MS Marvel I mentioned spider-gwen it's
Gwen Stacy but she's basically
spider-man gwenpool
again when Stacy but now Deadpool about
the only one that I could say like maybe
you could say isn't derivative would be
Bob agent of Hydra but let's be honest
Bob while I would love him to show up as
a supporting character in whatever they
do with Deadpool next he's not gonna get
his own fell
the point is when people make the
argument specifically in regards to
comic book movies when they see the
casting announcements for something like
the Eternals or zoe kravitz as Catwoman
and they say why can't you leave the
white male sis
straight characters alone why can't you
just add diversity with new characters
because it's not viable that argument
works as I said at the start in a vacuum
in a vacuum you can say there's no
reason to change the characters just
introduce new ones and if the characters
are good they'll become popular enough
where they get to be their own thing but
new characters don't become a thing they
just don't they haven't for a long time
not unless they can piggyback on someone
else and the ones that I mentioned the
ones that are all clearly derivative of
existing characters surprise surprise
get this same thing thrown at them why
are you giving us a female version of
Wolverine we have Wolverine do something
else do an original character why do we
have Miles Morales we already have a
spider-man you're just doing this for
inclusion make an original character
when we went originally it made if they
get made they don't make an impact the
only way to get in there is through
these stablish characters whether that
means someone new taking on a mantle or
whether that means changing in
adaptation and I would continue to argue
that more often than not these changes
are not just being done to please
minorities
I mean minorities by their definition
don't have
the most box office swing there are
minority of the market but in general
regardless of the reason even if it is
for inclusion even if the reason that
this is being done is strictly to
diversify the caste and to be more
inclusive making the argument that this
shouldn't be done instead new killers
should be introduced is kneecapping the
ability to ever get more diverse
representation either in the comics and
therefore by association in the films
now I suspect most people making this
argument don't realize that or haven't
thought about it enough to come to that
conclusion some of them might have and
some of them some of them might realize
that they're making an argument that
basically says oh don't do this thing
instead I'm going to assist you go off
and do this other thing that I know
won't work there are probably some but I
suspect a fair number of people who make
this argument don't realize that it
basically just becomes a reason why
diversifying these casts these
characters we just never happen so this
is gonna become another one of those
instances where when I see people making
that argument why don't you just create
a new character I'm just gonna start
linking to this video instead of
replying to comments what are your
thoughts on this on new characters being
introduced into comics about the changes
that are made in adaptation or when new
characters take on man
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]